Florida health officials say a child is
the first death in the state during this
year's flu season the child who has not
been identified tested positive for
influenza B and was not vaccinated the
CDC says the total number of pediatric
flu deaths last season was 183 that's
the most since they began keeping
records in 2004 a new national survey
puts the spotlight on some popular and
potentially dangerous myths about the
flu shot our doctor Tara nurullah is
here to explain what the data really
show hi so it's really tragic every time
we have to report on one of these
pediatric deaths but what this is is a
strong clear message to parents about
the importance of vaccination this
vaccine is safe it is the most effective
tool we have and we know that of the
hundred and eighty deaths last year 80
percent were in kids who are
unvaccinated and a recent study showed
that the vaccine has the power to reduce
deaths and healthy children by about
two-thirds when you look at the number
of kids vaccinated last year for the flu
it's about 60 percent that falls far
short of the national goal of 80 percent
why is this this survey point out a lot
of misconceptions thirty percent of
parents thought it caused autism thirty
percent thought it was a conspiracy
thirty percent said it doesn't work and
over half felt like the flu vaccine
could give their kids the flu none of
these things are true it's important
that we deal with the science and the
facts parents should speak to their
doctor if they have any questions
but again recommendations any child over
six months should be vaccinated it
should be done early before the end of
October and really even if it doesn't
match the strain again it can reduce the
severity of the flu it can reduce
complications of the flu officials have
said it's like wearing a seatbelt and
this is really a no-brainer
right did I hear we could do the nasal
two and that's effective this year it is
recommended by the CDC do either the flu
mist or the vaccine although the
American Academy of Pediatrics still
suggests that the shot over the eye
experience at first my son school sent a
note saying they needed proof of
vaccinations so they're taking this
seriously yes that's right Cara thank
you thank you